human beings are fascinated with the
astonishing behaviors of celebrities
will and Chad and I have prepared three
stories about your favorite celebrities
you must listen to them and render your
opinions this is celebrating celebrities
begin who's our favorite celebrities uh
who's your favorite celebrity how does
dudes you know our favorite celebrities
oh yeah dude you know is everything my
favorite celebrity my favorites like
just straight up celebrity celebrity
yeah I don't know I don't know how dudes
he knows our favorite celebrities or
what we why the [ __ ] I think yours is
probably the rock or I mean he's a
contemporary one I would say he's a
celebrity yeah I guess he's a yeah he's
a big celebrity who's your favorite
celebrity it doesn't matter the point is
this dude he's going to give us some
[ __ ] stories about him or something
and then we're gonna yeah I guess so
yeah that's how we do dudes Barrymore's
Pizza salad recipe has Foodies totally
divided the actress gave step-by-step
instructions on how to mix pizza
toppings with traditional salad
components on Tick Tock leaving fans to
weigh in with cries of drill no or leave
supportive messages like the chaos is
what I'm here for Will and chat is Drew
Barrymore's Pizza salad at culinary Leap
Forward or the end of humanity
okay I missed this I did not know that
Drew Barrymore made a pizza salad on
Tick Tock right this is exciting
celebrity news but the question was is
it a culinary Leap Forward or the end of
humanity
uh uh I I gotta say it's probably
somewhere in the middle I have to
imagine somebody has already done a
pizza salad prior to Drew Barrymore yeah
um and I don't think it's the end of
humanity but interesting to think about
interesting to talk about have you ever
had a pizza salad uh I think excuse me I
think that it is not the end of humanity
uh it's probably closer to a culinary uh
achievement or whatever the [ __ ] dudes
you said uh and no I've never had a
pizza salad what is that will you chop
up a bunch of pizza and put it in a
salad
I don't know I think maybe it's the
toppings off the pizza and then you mix
it with salad yeah so you don't have to
eat the bread yeah you don't have to eat
the bread no it's sour you just put
anything on salad and it's fine never
mind that you are also eating salad uh
you because there's calories in there
too
um I don't give a [ __ ] do you give a
[ __ ] about this I don't give a flying
I'm trying to I mean I get what doozy's
saying that you know celebrity news or
whatever I don't know if dudes he said
it's big business this time but it is it
is big business we do know that uh uh
yeah I don't care about this at all I
don't I will say that I don't care about
this at all eat your pizza however you
want as we look uh someone must someone
must intensely care about Drew
Barrymore's Pizza salad not us and not
here uh what's your favorite what's your
favorite pizza topping now that you're
uh a vegan I know what it is it's cashew
Rodrigo I actually don't like that that
weird cheese [ __ ] I like uh mushrooms I
like uh
uh that's about it yeah it's about it
just the mushrooms I like well congrats
to Drew Barrymore that would that's uh
that's yeah she's eating uh her Pizza
salad and I guess a lot of people are
into it I don't think it's the end of
the world nor do I think it's a culinary
leap as I said somewhere somewhere in
the middle it's like a regular meal is
what I feel like
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] all right fair
enough Billy Ray Cyrus and his
girlfriend fire Rose sparked engagement
rumors earlier this month when the
songstress flashed a sparkling ring on
her ring finger will and Chad did this
Australian born-leading lady cure Billy
Ray's achy breaky heart or is this all
an elaborate publicity stunt designed to
deflect attention away from a coming
nuclear war
now I understand what's going on okay uh
I actually I I agree with you to hear
that this is a distraction uh to keep
our minds off of the an inevitable
nuclear war there's some smaller nukes
that um
uh [ __ ] Vladimir Putin has has
amassed and is threatening to set off I
don't know exactly what that has to do
with Billy Ray Cyrus yeah that's what I
was going to ask you you think it is a
deflection of the coming nuclear war the
information about it who's making the
deflection do you think it's Billy Ray
Cyrus and uh his fiancee or whatever
taking this into their own hands or is
this a deep cover operation started by
Putin is Billy Ray Cyrus on Putin's
payroll it's definitely a deep cover
operation
these people
I don't want to care about Billy Ray
Cyrus give it get going into a diamond
mine looking for yeah he's looking for
her well Adrena Chrome down inside a
carbon
down there they breathe sulfur they eat
money Billy Ray Cyrus eats his own hair
why it's a deflection oh
these are globalish yeah who yeah
definitely this is uh I think that this
is probably I would uh I would agree
that this is definitely a distraction
who I don't know who owns the media
outlet that has let us know that Billy
Ray Cyrus's [ __ ] fiance has a [ __ ]
ring no you know what Chad I don't care
about this one cares deeply about it I
don't care about the person who cares
deeply about it
okay
I think that I mean is Billy Ray Cyrus
like newsworthy anymore I guess he is
right wasn't he just with Lil Nas X they
made a song with a little noise what is
that like four or five years old listen
all celebrity news is [ __ ] garbage
and nobody cares that's what I have I
don't think that's true I think it's
very especially where celebrity news
starts to cross over into like political
[ __ ] or social [ __ ] you know some of
that like I would argue Colin Kaepernick
kneeling uh when he was in the NFL that
is technically celebrity news what about
Aaron Rodgers uh eating uh horse paste
or whatever is that also celebrity news
horse Pace whatever the [ __ ] uh horse
stuff covered [ __ ] he took Ivermectin
yeah he took somebody I didn't [ __ ]
know that yeah I was pretty sure he took
this see now I know what the [ __ ] dudes
he's doing here what's up it's got you
and I doing celebrity news in the
[ __ ] segment I just said I don't give
a [ __ ] about it and now she clearly do
yeah I'm pontificating on [ __ ] how
many hours did you spend thinking about
up uh Aaron Rodgers taking Ivermectin no
hours but somehow you know about it yeah
I [ __ ] know about it because we know
about everything in this [ __ ] world
because dude you're [ __ ] doing Alex
Jones impersonations you don't care
about celebrity news
what
I think you care deeply about
celebrities shut the [ __ ] up you don't
know anything hey let me ask you
something Chad yeah let me ask you
something seriously you know you're one
of my absolute best Pals and uh yeah
cheers you're [ __ ] you're you're kind
of getting grinding my gears today I
just want to ask you yeah I want to ask
you this question you want to [ __ ] go
no no me neither that would be stupid
yeah we just get hurt dude yeah we get
hurt hold on dude when you have a real
fight dude and it's a shoot you can get
hurt brother yeah yeah then you got to
go to the hospital dude yeah dude they
need surgery to repair your [ __ ]
ligaments and Joints dude and then you
never walk again brother well that's
called an ACL replacement dude yeah and
that's tired Charles perogon it sounds
the most like Hulk Hogan I always try to
slow it down a little bit when I do okay
it doesn't work yeah all right well
lizzo just played an instrument with a
whole lot of history during a concert at
Washington DC's Capital One Arena lizzo
to work the night away while she played
a crystal flute gifted to President
James Madison by Claude Lawrence in
1813. will and Chad is lizzo the
greatest flutist in human history or was
this an Illuminati Deep Cover operation
designed to open a gate to hell and
Conquer with an army of demons
this is this
uh I don't give a [ __ ] about this either
but it's definitely way more interesting
to talk about than uh Billy Ray Cyrus's
fiance uh yeah lizzo played some [ __ ]
uh old ass flute right that's made out
of Crystal or something this thing
actually made it into my news feed the
other two things I did not know about
the Drew Barrymore Pizza salad and the
Billy Ray Cyrus getting engaged same
lizzo playing the flute made it into my
news feed and uh I thought it was
interesting I thought it was kind of an
awesome thing to do for the library but
I read about it so I do know something
about this the Library of Congress
basically hit her up and said you're
going to be in DC we have this Crystal
flute the James Madison had would you
like to play it on stage they offered it
to her and she was like [ __ ] yes yeah
she did it and it I don't know what kind
of attention it might have brought from
the public toward these weird historical
artifacts that reside in the Library of
Congress but uh I thought it worked
overall as a publicity stunt and I know
it like enraged some people or whatever
but I can't understand why why you would
give a [ __ ] enough I guess this is what
dudes doing here just literally finding
out if we give a [ __ ] enough about it or
if we think that this is opening a
portal to hell right I don't think it's
that yeah no it's it's definitely not
opening a portal to hell but for some
people it is because they get whipped up
about nothing yeah dig up more old
instruments and let [ __ ] whoever play
it now uh lizzo is an accomplished
flautist right uh there are some other
celebrities out there that play musical
instruments of course I don't know who
does well there's Billy Ray Cyrus we
just talked about him what if they gave
Billy Ray Cyrus a [ __ ] you know I
don't know a clarinet made of ivory
boring uh open up a portal to hell for
sure and then shove me into it and and
that's what we're doing here in doozy
hell there was one of my favorite movies
as a kid was this animated movie called
rock and roll in it a weird like rat
character that's been radiated by a
nuclear fallout
finds this perfect voice and uses music
to open a portal to hell and summon a
demon oh yeah if anybody's ever seen
rock and roll
you know what I'm talking about if you
haven't check that [ __ ] out immediately
it's a fantastic movie made back in the
late 80s and I had all these [ __ ]
people that did original songs for it
Lou Reed Debbie Harry Earth Wind and
Fire just a massive [ __ ] cast of
people Again original music in the 80s I
didn't I've never heard of this one most
people heard of this made in Canada dude
your home country oh I am from there
that's right you're correct about that
you know what else is from there Gordon
Lightfoot all members of uh rush and
tragically hip Avril Lavigne brother
well hold on a second dude
oh
what is the new Prince Adam order
brother never mind that dude if you're
listening along
um
uh yeah now I'm now okay well it doesn't
matter these are thoughts and they're
gonna come out of my [ __ ] head hole
anyway yeah I do uh you you read about
this already yeah the lizzo flute thing
yeah and doozies clocked that just like
doozy is clocked uh this [ __ ] movie
that you're talking you're talking about
rock and roll yeah
oh you think it was putting rock and
roll into the lizzo thing uh yeah I
think that possible I I don't know I
hope that we never talk about celebrity
news ever again that's what I do know I
don't mind celebrity news as you know I
mind it I watched The Bachelor and do
another show about the bachelor I
consider them celebrities
[Music]
[Music]
please shut up and then